[Music]
and problem solitaire news submitted by
Aaron pen Indiana must pay a convicted
killer of 425 K after throwing him in
solitary confinement for four years oh
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] okay it doesn't even
matter how much money they give him that
guy is [ __ ] for a life yeah he's
cuckoo now but he's gonna be even a
paper therapist or something
oh no if that's just reversible that's
crazy well now he's $425,000 richer
that's not even that much for four years
of insanity they literally made a joke
they're probably probably made a Joker
for years with no sunlight here just
like this and no people get out for one
time a day I think it's like 30 minutes
or an hour a day of sunlight that's they
accidentally threw him in there so he
for they forgot him or oh so here's what
happened so this guy his name is Jay
he's serving time for murder and other
offenses he went into solitary
confinement in 2009 but he was never
given a clear explanation for his
segregation or the chance to argue his
case against staying there and so the
state only allows a maximum of 30 days
in solitary confinement before officials
must conduct a review but that never
happened with this guy how do they know
that that never happened because that
record yeah and so he was they were he
was able to sue the state and so the
that's when a settlement determined that
the state must pay him roughly one
hundred thousand dollars every year that
he spent in isolation which racked up to
425 but that's crazy
okay so there had to be a lawyer or
somebody that captured price see that
yeah like you got a lawyer to even talk
to maybe finally someone checked up on
him there's someone heard about the case
and then like a jailer or someone or or
like Oh or like a lawyer heard about it
yeah cuz like I imagine it's like
solitary confinement probably in the
most isolated part of the jail so once
they lock them in if they don't check up
on my flight baffles just in there if
there's no - what about folders do you
have to burn people food
that's true but then the food guy it
might not be a guard might just be a
food person so they're not in target
they're just coming in slice yeah they
might not know
yeah they described his home as a cold
concrete tomb with a solid steel steel
door and that allowed him no direct
contact with others work or recreation
that's crazy you didn't have literally
anything for four years do people kill
themselves in that place when they're in
there for longer than 30 days would you
guys do it for a billion dollars now for
four years
what are you do that you get out you get
your billion dollar you're not even the
same person no way you're not gonna get
it hmm maybe like a year maybe a year
I'd be down no it can't be it can't be
it's gotta be the same experience this
man when he did it for way less can you
imagine being this guy and you don't
[ __ ] know if you're ever getting out
not some people can that [ __ ] crazy
mm-hm you survive for four years at
least for four at least I know in four
years I'm getting out but you don't even
know how long
punch time is passed yeah yeah you don't
know the difference between night and
day yeah if you're told for years inside
of just thinking about it I can't
[ __ ] do it I would rather be told for
years been to [ __ ] I don't know what
yet happening theory you're like okay
four years and then you can logically
figure it out but you if you were in
there if you can barely sit still yeah
I'm thinking between I'm thinking
between four years or never being told
at all those are the two options I'm
thinking of those two yeah that's so
obviously you're right I have to do it
guys you have to think about it in that
hypothetical because wouldn't you rather
be told obvious rather but the
parameters but you're not even
entertaining the thought is what I'm
saying because you're too scared to
think about that no no I was like no I
mean we're just fighting about you for
years have you let out you'd be let out
of seven for years I know exactly how
much time I'm gonna get up I still
wouldn't do it for a billion dollar I'm
not saying I'm gonna do it I'm gonna say
I'm basically saying that
would you do it yeah I never said I was
gonna do it I wouldn't want to do it but
the point is if you had to do it right
oh happy rameters have changed yeah and
I'm gonna get a billion yeah I'd rather
no I'm gonna get out obviously right but
how would you easy okay now that now
moving on to the next point obviously
now moving on to the next point how
would you spend your time bro what do
you do do you remember what we talked
about is masturbating got this guy on it
that this guy was um he like made of a
bet with his friend and he was like in
the restroom he literally just let his
imagination go you know like but he
trained for that though yeah I mean
honestly it you just darkness but that's
that's different cuz you're in darkness
and 2015 was four years ago what the
[ __ ] were you doing in 2015 I imagine
you there and do any of that up until
now nothing exactly do [ __ ] what do you
mean how would you spend your time
because you don't have anything to do
you're just in a box yeah Brady what are
the rules of solitary comfort do you
start clicking or counting I guess
that's what I would do I would just
joining on one two three and I would try
to make the night ya know I tried to
make a concrete and so at least I can
keep track of time
Oh Cameron County for a month straight
up so Alcatraz they let you do a tour
and like there's solitary confinement
profess and they said that one of the
prisoners was there for a long time and
he felt like he pulled the button off of
his like prisoner outfit and hit to pass
the time he would drop the button and it
would be pure darkness and then he would
try to find the button and he just did
that over at all I think the rule with
solitary confinement is you're supposed
to have an hour of sunlight every day
yeah you need to get an hour have you
seen it how I do it or at least orange
is the new fitness so how are you doing
on that okay accurate show how do they
do it on that Barry
like that show but like in that show
they they just have like this little box
that's connected to solitary confinement
and it's outside like but but you're
still in a confined space you're still
like you don't even get to feel like
boys
it's bars now you could feel it but you
get the Sun you but you're just like
still like bars like you it's like a
you're not allowed to have any social
interaction but dude I will take that
over nothing this got for sure because
dude happen at least you know what a day
passes yeah and have you ever been in
like when it's really cold and you're
like cover like when you want to just
Gary blanket what it's all dark I've
never been in that miss Gary blanket
that's almost just like solitary
confinement in the window down can you
do two years no there was an article
about a psychologist who tried to go
three days in solitary not solitary
confinement like in the jail just like
in a in a room with no windows or light
coming in just three days and he was
already going crazy and that's a
psychologist but do you think that were
different because we're so used to
simulation all the time like I could try
to put my phone down and in 30 minutes
I'm like [ __ ] I'm just gonna look at my
phone yeah
like have you even meditating for like
seven minutes I'm like okay like I'm
almost done you know like it's crazy
what do you do
I know so this is Jay oh he's the guy so
he ended up she wasn't working out in
there he shot his ex-girlfriend why
would work out that's what did she die
he killed her so he alright well he
fatally shot his ex-girlfriend back in
1995 he was convicted in 1997 so he's
not due to be released until 2036 Oh
what is he gonna do with all that money
get snacks for everything still like um
even murderers did they get put in
solitary confinement like right off the
jump like I feel like they got so much
of me a troublemaker
in 2009 when you get in trouble in jail
exactly that's what I thought
did they talk about if he's mentally all
right no [ __ ] no I don't think I've even
done tests on him like is there even
money in the system to like make us the
thing is that some Indiana Department of
Correction spokesperson said that so
quote we continue to deny any faults
wrongdoing or liability with respect to
litigation that's what they have to say
I guess they don't want to worsen the
lawsuit but then that's the one person
we found out about imagine how many
people have died in there that we don't
even know about and we'll never see the
light of day especially ones with no
family no one to go check up on them you
know what else is crazy too because like
who's gonna pay this amount to this man
we are it taxpayers it just builds my
mind how someone found this and and and
someone hasn't reported it in four years
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on like
it is family it's gotta be like family
I wonder how uncle my dad is doing four
years is such a long time do you think
he knew he was in there for that long
[ __ ] you probably went crazy before he
you then have your room been in their
closet and the light bulb goes out what
I don't have a light bulb they even
withstand that I'm just gonna sit in the
closet no sometimes it [ __ ] you know
power goes off recently I did I did some
condition when they and that was a very
first time I was so proud of myself
because I actually turned off the light
want to stay there whole last hour and
pitch darkness [ __ ] huge for me oh
it's a one hour because I did it it's
really comfortable yeah but now we have
brie I know I know that's why it's like
it's funny because you know it's all
it's how we make sense of our world
right so to me something's very relaxing
and comfortable which can be terrifying
to someone else but that's what's funny
to me yeah Stephanie are you laying down
it's like salt water so immediately flow
and also you're in complete silence
unless like you decided to have the
music on which I did for the first half
and then the last half I was completely
experiences no sensory like that's the
goal right do not feel here's the EVP I
didn't know what they teach black and
silent the whole time but all I could
think about the whole time was who I was
gonna get off waivers for my fantasy
football team and then I was like who
are they playing like I just strategize
the whole time that hour went by so fast
I was like I need another hour my brain
didn't even relax
have you guys ever farted in there no
but you hear the bubbles you know what
does [ __ ] up you're like whole
relaxation session though is if you get
any of that water and your [ __ ] eye
that's just stings like oh but if it
goes in in it [ __ ] it all of your minds
assault or something yeah do there's so
much salt and you're just spraying your
[ __ ] eyes yeah and then you got AG
like get back into the Zen and it's all
that [ __ ] relaxation music playing in
the background I had the music on yeah I
like it was like fight it was a
competition okay
turn my brain I realized harder does it
help you without the music
um I think next time I would do the
music because complete silent my brain
just goes crazy just maybe you just
don't you're not carrying anything in
here cuz if you're carrying a lot in
here then you've gone into like you're
forced to think about whatever is like
in here you know I'm like relaxed and
then it's like well if I pick up you
know minshew this and then like okay
every time my mind started creating a
thought I would just go back to like
focusing on my brain I would literally
be saying in my head on my breathing in
breathe good job girl Lee then you're
doing great you're like cool we're here
in the darkness we got this wish we
could trade thoughts as you start to see
color that's when it's dope No
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]